greetings from podcastville the church
is brought to you from
by stamps.com listen
this holiday season with nobody able to
travel to their loved ones people are
going to be mailing more stuff than ever
before
the post office is going to be busy you
don't need that hassle
with stamps.com you can mail anything
from the convenience of your own home
plus it saves you money with deep
discounts
you can't get at the post office let me
explain something to you
i've been with stamps.com for maybe 10
years now my wife uses it
she loves it she loads up the boxes she
leads them outside
and the mailman picks them up stamps.com
brings the post office into the comfort
of your own home now
don't spend a minute of your holiday
season at the post office this year
sign up for stamps.com instead there's
no risk
my with my code church c-h-u-r-c-h
you got a special offer that includes a
four week trial
plus ready for this one free postage
and a digital scale i would put the
digital scale up but they'll throw me
under the [ __ ] jail so
i can't do that stuff i can't have a
scale on that and people think i'm
wearing stuff and
they'll send a picture to the cops or
whatever but anyway no long-term
commitments
or contracts it's easy go to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
home page and press in church
c-h-u-r-c-h
that stamps dot com president church
and you'll never go to the post office
again god damn it
the church is also brought to you by
blue chew
guys remember the days when you'd wake
up all you had to do was [ __ ] just
think
of like a dead and your dick would get
as hard as a [ __ ]
piece of concrete all of a sudden i
i tear my [ __ ] hamstring and i'm
having [ __ ] problems with my dick
talking
here's a guy who who knocked up his wife
at [ __ ] 50. listen
if the [ __ ] week if the wood is weak
uncle joey's got a fix for you
blue chew it's the first chewable dick
pill
same fda approved active ingredients as
viagra
and cialis this isn't the horny goat
weed you get from [ __ ]
whatever that [ __ ] mud is down at the
corner store
this is [ __ ] science and right now
they've got a special offer
for the for the joint family visit
bluechew.com that's
bluee chew.com it's that easy
and get your first shipment free when
you're pressing code
joey j-o-e-y just pay for the five
dollar shipping and again
that's blue like the color of your dick
vein that's gonna be popping the [ __ ]
out of that helmet
you're gonna be spreading blue dick
juice all over the [ __ ] place so go
to bluetooth.com
and use code joey listen maybe you don't
have problems with erectile dysfunction
but you want to be remembered
how do you [ __ ] tell these [ __ ]
things and going there deep
deep deep into the murky waters i would
never eat a ton of these things
but anyway you know what i'm saying you
always want to be prepared you never
want to
give a bad performance that it's covered
if you're gonna
if you're gonna die it might as well be
for [ __ ] a good reason
take two of these and call me in the
morning wake up in the morning she's
[ __ ] cockeyed
that's it go to bluetooth.com use code
church
let's [ __ ] get this party started
give that indian some [ __ ] gin
candles lick [ __ ]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here
wednesday the 14th of march it's a
beautiful
[ __ ] day to be alive it's been
an interesting week
let's start with what's been
crack-a-lacking for starters i want to
apologize to you guys
i did not go to my friends awake uh
it wasn't that i did out of you know i
didn't want to be there or whatever
monday was a holiday and the kids were
off from school
my wife had already made plans to my
wife had a full [ __ ] day
we were supposed to go to uh down the
shore with another family and the kid
the raindroid that
but anyway you put it she had a six
o'clock meeting with some moms in a
neighborhood
to plan some [ __ ] i'm happy they
involved i was dressed
and ready to go you know it's a
55-minute drive up there
but she didn't get home till like 10 to
7 i would have never made it in the rain
and whatnot
you know my heart goes out to the
holloway family you guys know how much i
love them
uh and the other thing is the truth
you know what man i [ __ ] hate wakes
it's just i forgot the bad part about
living in
new jersey that there's a lot of [ __ ]
wakes
and you gotta go to a lot of ways and
let me tell you something nothing
bothers me more
than [ __ ] wakes because it takes me
back to the original four that i went to
a my father when i was three b
anthony balzano in the eighth grade b my
mother in 79
d [ __ ] dominic special
in [ __ ] 80. so i had anthony balzano
i had two kids i was best friends with
and my mom vanished within [ __ ] three
years you know what
my weight days are done every time i go
to awake i drag that [ __ ] cat back in
that luggage gets in
and for two days my head is all [ __ ]
up and i don't need that
i need to be tip top my goo for you
[ __ ] i don't need to be dragged
cause it reflects in my writing
it reflects on who i am so my heart goes
out to the roger holloway family
i mean the hollow ways are gone timmy's
still around you know i always talk
about timmy and i talked to him i
checked up on him yesterday
he felt so awkward he didn't even go
uh you know timmy's gone through a lot
and i'm here for him and he's here for
me so
that's what this is all about you know
uh going to awake and making believe
is [ __ ] i said a prayer here i lit a
candle here
and my day was [ __ ] complete and
that's how i made
my [ __ ] uh piece with it you know so
i'm always straight up with you guys
only you let you know what i'm feeling
what i'm thinking what i'm doing
just so you know listen we're all human
here just because i go on stage just
because you see me on the tv
doesn't mean i have the same things that
you guys are going through
i go through all that [ __ ] i'd read
those patreon emails
people are having a hard time and i get
it you know some guy wrote me an email
about uh
he wanted to come see me last wednesday
in point pleasant
but the fear struck again i get it i
almost [ __ ] made a u-turn 18
times so we're all coping what's on our
table right now
i'm just here to make it a little easier
for you if i can take your mind off
for an hour we got to [ __ ] it out since
it's uncle joey's joint today we're
going to smoke a [ __ ] dude why not
i got the weed that [ __ ] trump smoked
when he got rid of colvin
so what the [ __ ] are we doing here what
are we going to do sit down and just
talk to each other
listen if you got offended by bill
burr's monologue
go [ __ ] yourself and it's to the point
better yet i've never [ __ ] uh enabled
somebody
go hang yourself because it ain't gonna
work out for you all right
bill burr is a [ __ ] brilliant [ __ ]
comic
bill burr is one of the most brilliant
comics working today okay
he's married to an african-american
woman he's
cool as [ __ ] and he went up there and
give it to i read some guy that
after his first three minutes i had to
turn it off and shut
up well listen do yourself a favor right
now get a shot of cobra and stick it up
your ass
and go for bro cause you ain't gonna
make it it's gonna get tough you know
what i'm saying he's just not gonna make
it
bill burr is [ __ ] amazing and what he
did was [ __ ] brilliant
and you know why people got pissed off
because he wasn't [ __ ] lying see
nobody ever wants to hear the [ __ ]
truth nobody
ever wants to hear the truth god forbid
you tell somebody [ __ ] truth
they want you to blow smoke up their ass
we're in a society
that you can't oh no you said that who
gives a [ __ ] what they said
you got kids you got bills to pay then
what do you give a [ __ ]
turn it off i haven't i watched saturday
night live
just for bill let's get something
straight in my world
they should be honored that for [ __ ]
the first time in years
they had a real comic on the [ __ ]
stage don't get me wrong they had chris
rockwell
on the stage but he was a staff member
at some time
i'm talking a hardcore [ __ ] road
comic that's a [ __ ] savage
it's bill burr just him being in those
sketches with those [ __ ]
you know io people whatever the [ __ ]
they are improv olympic and whatever
they're both for sale there's a reason
that business is going out of business
there's no business it's a bunch of
people sitting around
watching eight guys doing sketches [ __ ]
you [ __ ] i go on stage by myself with a
microphone
my balls my heart and what i got to say
you can't beat that when you're [ __ ]
on a set you got some guy writing lines
for you
for all you comedic actors that they
call stand-ups nothing bothers me more
when they call a guy like will on that
sweetheart of a guy
a comedian it pisses me the [ __ ] off
he's not a comedian
he's a scripted comedic actor we
are stand-ups we are in the [ __ ]
bowels
with walls behind us with four people in
front of us
vying for whatever 15 bucks or whatever
the [ __ ] you are
it's a different animal so remember
sound out loud and stand up
two different [ __ ] situations that's
a bunch of people that get together in
chicago and they go to
second city and they train for four or
five years
on how to do sketches or whatever that's
great but i came from a different
[ __ ] school i came from the schools
i'm up there by myself i'm taking all
the heat myself and i congratulate bill
burr
for doing what the [ __ ] he's doing who
gives a [ __ ] they're trying to cancel
him on twitter
and even [ __ ] curse he didn't even
curse
and you can see the audience there's
even a little men's emote like
we don't know if we should laugh get
your life together
this is the one big change i found
between la
and me being here right now people got a
sense of humor again
you could say stupid little things and
people giggle
in l.a people look at you listen i never
felt it i never
i never uh fed it
fed i was never part of that circle
there
no matter what i did and i didn't want
to be a part of that circle that was the
problem i used to get invited to those
holiday parties all the time
i didn't fit this is where i fit i fit
in perfectly right here
all the people around me staten island
brooklyn new york new jersey
they understand my sense of humor i
understand this i went to a second grade
party friday night
with the second grade teacher she had
all the students there was outside they
were playing the night before [ __ ]
whatever
and i started talking to some of the
parents and i was blown the [ __ ] away
they were all a breath of fresh air
why because it wasn't about instagram
friends
and it wasn't about oh my god that's you
know i'm
i'm over all that [ __ ] if you're over 20
[ __ ] one
get your [ __ ] together if you get
insulted about words or whatever
it's time it's time to say you know what
i gotta throw my hands up
this is [ __ ] you're gonna cancel
billboard or whatever yeah
you can't do it you're in no [ __ ]
danger it's never gonna fly
so you little cancel people go back
under your [ __ ] huts
and go watch [ __ ] walking dead or
whatever the [ __ ] it is that you [ __ ]
half of [ __ ] watch
you got me all [ __ ] fired up already
on a [ __ ] wednesday morning
[ __ ]
huh well you gotta find me to [ __ ] up on
a wednesday morning
with you you get insulted over words
your mother told you sticks and stones
will break my bones and words will never
hurt me
if you're under [ __ ] dirty and you
never heard that go smack your mother in
the face
because that's the first thing your mom
tells you when you come home crying like
a little [ __ ]
they they say i look like a monkey you
do look like a [ __ ] monkey
now suck it in go out there and play i
used to have big [ __ ] ears when i was
a kid
i look like something from a different
[ __ ] planet i still do
i don't give a [ __ ] call me whatever the
[ __ ] you want sticks and stones will
break my bones
words can never hurt you if a guy is not
even talking about you
what the [ __ ] are you so worried about
oh you there was
men yesterday writing [ __ ] give me a
[ __ ] breather man
if that's your way of getting [ __ ] or
standing by women it's your actions that
can count okay
so i don't want to hear nothing about
nothing let's spark this number it's
wednesday where the [ __ ] are you going
what are you doing with your life that's
so [ __ ] special
you're gonna sit behind a computer with
your white shirt on a pajama bottom
scratching your [ __ ] balls you didn't
wash
you just put water on your ass so you
could zoom all [ __ ] day knock it the
[ __ ] off
now whoever you're zooming with they go
[ __ ] themselves you ain't got time for
this [ __ ]
you're all zoomed up i'll be what i'm
saying
how many people are gonna die from zoom
addiction pretty soon
pretty soon there's gonna be [ __ ] uh
za w
any day now any day wait till these
flags get a rogue going
za zoom anonymous
my name is joe and i've been addicted to
zoom
for [ __ ] eight years now get the [ __ ]
give me a breather man
[ __ ] you and zoom here's to you
[ __ ] hope you're having a great
day hope you're smiling
hope you have love in your heart because
that's all that matters right now
during this cold if you're broke who
gets a fire everybody's waiting for
another employment check good luck
whatever the least you can do is [ __ ]
just smile for one minute
and give your soul a breather you're
gonna live if chris christie live
you're gonna live that fat [ __ ] lived
with asthma
and sleep apnea and fungi toenails just
like me
you're in no danger you're sitting at
home 84 pounds you don't want to leave
the house because
colbert's outside listen give it a
breather now if you live in l.a
and you live in new york you can't go
out at night because somebody will hit
you in the head with a brick okay
rick moranis and won't be doing any
movies soon that [ __ ] got sucker
punched
up in the upper west side if you're
living on the two coast
once it turns dark mind your business
you know what i'm saying you don't know
nothing you don't want to know nothing
you only want to get food delivered
because you don't know if the guys
delivering food is going to [ __ ] rob
you that's how serious it is in new york
but here's to you [ __ ] on a
beautiful [ __ ] wednesday morning
oh this is the [ __ ] this thing chris
christie smoked
before they let him out they gave him
this and a cheeseburger and they said
it's time to go home chris christie
they aim like three white castle burgers
that [ __ ] was happier than [ __ ]
tremendous [ __ ] tremendous otherwise
that we can do this in america i'm 57
years old listen to me
all you [ __ ] that are
anti-american whatever
i am 57 years old like i told my
daughter the other day what other
country
can the 57 year old go up on stage with
no material talk [ __ ] and get paid
america what the [ __ ] are you doing and
what are you complaining about [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] who's president you got
to run your own game
your game is life that's all that
[ __ ] matters
somebody being there you [ __ ]
arguing about politics 10 hours a day
you're [ __ ] just talking for talking
talk about the most important things in
your life your kids
your wives what you do for your life
that's it everything else i don't want
to hear about the gop
or the holding back who gives a [ __ ] get
a gun what are you bothering me fly
i'm waiting for my unemployment check i
hope to buy a gun
because you got to earn [ __ ] sucker
you're making 900 car payments you know
what i'm saying
look at this smoke in here this is the
way i like it now we're talking about
uncle joey's joint on a [ __ ]
wednesday
if you haven't seen the comedy store
documentary i made it to episode second
and i just made a comment like i was
lucky to be on there
and my boy the director mike being to
call me he's like are you [ __ ] crazy
you're all i just was making a joke
listen in today's world you never know
where you're gonna end up
you know what i'm saying you cut you cut
a movie you're not guaranteed to be in
it
especially with all the chitter chat
that's going around people are scared
now
so i'm very happy that mike being to put
me in that documentary because he knows
that i was at that comedy store for 23
years of my life the same way he was we
all have our [ __ ]
we all have our personal vietnam stories
from the comedy store
whether they're good or bad but hey
i'm here in this house because of the
comedy store
the county store was that influential in
my life the comedy store documentary
the last weeks was freddy prince was so
good
that i came downstairs i cried and i
free fell in love with tommy again
and that's what i wanted to do during
this culvert
i didn't care about the business side of
it that had nothing to do with it
all i wanted was to refall
in love with comedy again i don't know
if you're a musician i don't know if
you're an
artist you're a painter you draw
whatever you're a circus act
you know once you get involved in the
game you forget what the game about
is about it becomes money and netflix
and this guy wants to do a special with
you and this guy's doing this
and sometimes in all that catch up you
forget about the love that you had for
that art you know
taking things for granted you know you
got your wife
you got your girlfriend she does this
you do that dude
and also boom one day she's dead and you
realize you took it for granted
i took comedy for granted for a long
time not because i'm an [ __ ]
just because there were so many other
things going on
i'm happy things slowed down and i got
to fall in love with connie
you know what part i am with comedy
right now we're holding hands
walking down the street we haven't even
[ __ ] i haven't even seen her tits yet
i haven't even gone to try to go to the
first base
we're just walking and talking about
what interests we have that's i'm
falling in love with comedy again
i'm telling you this from the bottom of
my heart for a while that i was a little
disenchanted
it was a stand-up it was the business
side and the [ __ ]
and you gotta [ __ ] sell tickets i
wanted all that to disappear
i wanted just to fall in love with
comedy again
i ordered the [ __ ] book again i
[ __ ]
went back to swear one i mean i'm
digging it
i watch the rodney specials i watch bill
burr again the
night i actually watch that night live
which i
[ __ ] won't even put on you know i put
on the first week for punky
johnson the girl she's from the comedy
store i give her all my [ __ ] heart
and soul and congratulate her
for becoming a a member of saturn i live
so i watched it because of her
but after a while i just saw her first
sketch and then i [ __ ] fell asleep or
something
and i watched it this week because of
bill burr you know
i've been watching a lot of stand-up
lately a lot of hicks
a lot of canis and a lot of dice
a lot of richer pride the night actually
came in here and put a richard pryor
album down
[ __ ] lord turned off the lights and
just sat here high as [ __ ]
and listened to his was it something i
said i'm just re-acquainting myself with
comedy again
i'm just falling i'm doing those four
shows in october
and then i'm pulling back it's like she
had to go on a trip
you ever start dating a woman and all
said right in the middle where you start
when you're ready where do you [ __ ]
awesome she's got to go on a trip for
work for four weeks
that's what's happened to me so now
that's gonna drive me even crazier
i'm gonna write right while i'm doing
the movie i'm gonna write
i got some good ideas cooking and then
we'll see what december looks like if
december looks good
we'll go [ __ ] uh
we'll cook for a couple jersey dates
together my man sam tripley's got the
comedy dojo you know how much i love sam
and how much he was there for me
i might as well go with sam at the
comedy dojo
i'll keep doing uncle vinnie's joint my
boy danny just contacted me
he's got a couple weekly rooms all over
the [ __ ] state
you know he's not going to put my name
on the flyer i'm just going to pop up
and do 10 or 15.
and i'm very happy with that but i'm
getting a chance to fall in love with
comedy again
and that is [ __ ] great man and that's
good for you [ __ ] and you know
what else is good for you [ __ ]
but i don't give a [ __ ] that's a triple
threat now
what are you gonna do take away the
joint you have to [ __ ]
bring ten puerto ricans to take this
[ __ ] away from me
and guess what they don't want it
because this [ __ ] is packed in [ __ ]
heat today what do you think i'm doing
lately i'm showing up with some [ __ ]
susquehanna jersey we grown in morris
plains
oh [ __ ] yourself you know me
[ __ ] this was cut before the
fire a long time ago
i haven't spoken about it but i do miss
some of my friends in california i told
my wife the other day that i felt bad
that
it didn't work out it didn't work out
you know what are you saying by working
on mercy graduating high school
maybe in [ __ ] 67 or whatever the [ __ ]
i'm gonna be
and us moving to some retirement
community and that's it that's right
and me living in l.a being at the store
you know i felt like uh in a way i
failed but we didn't
but i miss it and one of the people i
miss i miss brent
from subconscious jiu jitsu that was my
brother
all the way to the end i miss uh roy
from corona muay thai i miss my
neighbors
i miss [ __ ] uh back to wellness
that's where i went for acupuncture
that's why i went for my chiropractor
i miss bully busters makita you know i
miss so
many people eddie bravo i spoke to
yesterday
i missed that crazy conspiracy [ __ ] i
missed sam tripley with all my heart
but let me tell you who i i missed and i
didn't know i missed him
until uh yesterday morning
was and i even talked about him with
jimmy florentine
when we went down to the uh to the
record store i want to thank
vintage vinyl and woodbridge for hooking
me up with the [ __ ] goods yesterday
and trust me they still got another 50
albums i got to buy
i just went light yesterday because i
had my daughter with me so i couldn't
act like a [ __ ] [ __ ] like geek out
in front of my daughter but my daughter
found something
she found both longest yards together
the one with adam sandler
and the one with [ __ ] reynolds so i
gave a copy of it to luke
jimmy's boy because he loves the [ __ ]
movie so i said you got to watch the
original two which you probably won't
like
because the 70s the movies were a little
slow they got their message through here
but movies were just a little slow i was
telling uh
you know jimmy florentino to write down
that
i was just scared of being you know not
scared i was i was sick and tired of
being
alone yeah i had lee and i had my man
steve simone and dean delray who i
missed with
all my [ __ ] heart i missed the comedy
story with all my heart
i'm gonna tell you it was a good guy and
if you get a chance
i know you're gonna watch it anyway uh
the cabin
with bert kreicher crasher put me in the
first episode between you and me again
in my [ __ ] delusional uh
marijuana mind i thought they were going
to cut me out netflix whatever
i was expecting to get the cut and [ __ ]
out of there but
oh my god somebody sent me the link this
morning they sent me a link a few days
ago to watch it earlier
and i watched it and i was very
surprised i think it's a great [ __ ]
show
and bert was very very good to me look
man i appreciate you guys that went out
to hackard ohio last week
to see jimmy florence and he told me
like i told you [ __ ]
from now on jimmy comes into your
neighborhood you do me the personal
favor
you just pay for a ticket or wait after
the show and go buy a shirt
or cd go support yesterday i went to buy
albums with him
and on the way back we stopped by his
house and this was interesting
we were talking one thing led to the
other and he showed me an arm because
you see this guy
he goes i already bought this up on
[ __ ] itunes and amazon
but i don't have the album i bought it
because the guy is such a great [ __ ]
guy
and i want to support the band right now
because they can't do it
that's chimney's way of thinking you
know i bought a couple albums and stuff
like that but i didn't buy music coming
from that perspective
from new bands i just got turned down to
a couple new bands this morning
and i'll be buying their albums support
them
and i know you can't support everybody i
know that you guys are [ __ ] working
hard for your dollar
but when i want to thank you for
supporting jimmy florentine
the other guy burke chrysler you
[ __ ] already are paying to go
see him so
but i want you to know how good of a guy
he is you know
bert uh every christmas had me over
he had my family over every easter uh
you know all limits you know
isla in fact isla used to go [ __ ]
mercy goes in my room and starts playing
my toys you know mercy just
kids don't listen my daughter if i buy
her a toy
it's good for two [ __ ] days and then
she forgets all about
for six weeks i had her on the [ __ ]
tic tac toy [ __ ]
video and i told i would buy that thing
if she behaved on the whole trip
from california to jersey and she was a
[ __ ] angel
and one day we're making a run for
something they go hey
look at target right there let's go in
there and i took her into target
and i told her do what you need to do
get a couple of [ __ ] dolls or
whatever
she brought him home i didn't see her
the rest of the day now i go in there
she's playing with legos she hasn't
talked about it
that's kids you know we're saying
someone when we would go over the
islands
to birds she would go right to isla's
room
my daughter scared the dogs my daughter
wasn't scared of birds big [ __ ] dog
for no reason
she would go into kyle's room and play
and i would hang out with bird
good man good man and i miss him i
missed theo too
but i missed my times over at burke
christ's house
so when i watched the cabin the person
that came to my mind is with
rest his soul you know i mean this in a
positive way when ralphie
may fell into his dollhouse outside his
house when he
when we were younger years ago we had a
[ __ ] dollhouse not we
chrysler and his daughters had a die
house outside this man cave
and as we were walking out me and bert
were talking about whatever ralphie was
waddling behind us
and all of a sudden we just hear boy
and we turned around and ralph he's like
get me out of here player i slipped in
the darkness and we had to carry him on
there and
the house was smashed
i was thinking about all the nights
i went over to burke chrysler's house
with my family it was just uh
just to do stupid [ __ ] but one christmas
guys christmas in l.a is like [ __ ]
60 degrees you know what i'm saying it
might turn to 50
[ __ ] the wind blows or something
but this one time we went over there
tremendous and then the pool opened
and uncle burt starts [ __ ] around
saying i'm thinking of jumping in the
pool and all this [ __ ] right
so a kid jumped in the pool and all the
other kids wouldn't jump in
and mercy goes i jump in the pool and
birth's like i dare you mercy
and mercy's like watch this and she
[ __ ] there's a mercy's like three
guys
mercy love to [ __ ] swim and jump in
the water and stuff
it's night time it's [ __ ] cold out
they didn't believe it mercy's like i'll
go in and they're like mercy mercy go
go go go and my daughter started looking
at the water
and she started getting fired up and
also she started [ __ ] running to the
thing
and before she ran the pool she stopped
and she goes dad
hold my ring i gave some [ __ ] little
[ __ ] rings she got the cracker jack
box or some [ __ ]
and she hit the pool and we [ __ ] died
a laughter
and that was a memory we'd have to tape
it we have to take a picture of it
we just laughed our asses off ever since
that day bert
and mercy got tighter so she asked me
about a week ago how's uncle bird doing
so the whole thing so you know man i
said some things a few weeks ago
about l.a and i realized now that i do
miss some of my friends
and uh it's fine we communicate
we talk we chit-chat from time to time
and that's it i checked up on v theo a
lot of you people said check up on the i
checked up montiel he was fine you know
he's going through what you're going
through
do we make the right decision moving
here what am i going to do with my life
what happens in six months do i take the
vaccine
what what the [ __ ] it's just too many
[ __ ] things
so people are at their [ __ ] peak so i
get it i get it if you're upset
i called everybody i can i check in i
check in with lee i check in with steve
simone
and that's it that's the best you can do
i'm [ __ ] stoned already i love it you
know what i'm saying don't take much
these days
i've been kind of you know you can't
smoke all day because
i'm busy i got the kid i got the wife i
got [ __ ] to do in the daytime
but when we do have a little chance to
take our tail like this
we gotta smoke a little number from time
to time just to throw you off you know
what i'm saying
just to let you know i still got you
i feel good i've been working out but
even right
my sleep has been [ __ ] tremendous uh
you know i got a good seven hours
straight now no more staying up late
nights
no more nothing if you see me up late
night it's because i probably fell
asleep like at 9 30
and now it's 3 30 in the morning i'm
more like lurking like a [ __ ] animal
that happens to me
it hasn't happened in the last couple of
weeks i thought i think it happened like
two weeks ago i woke up like at four
and i'll stay up i play instead of
laying there and fighting myself and
being angry
[ __ ] it i get up i write a little bit
and i [ __ ] around and tweet and get
everything ready so when i come back
later on
everything's [ __ ] done for me
tomorrow i got an appointment with the
heart doctor
to make sure everything's alright it's
by [ __ ] uh zoom
from california so hopefully he [ __ ]
uh
i gotta go on zoom so hopefully he
[ __ ] uh
submits of me to a doctor here not that
my heart is bad or whatever but
all this anxiety hasn't helped so i'm in
the same position as you [ __ ]
but like i said you can't be
like that guy that sent me the thing and
he was my anxiety tackled me again
listen we're all going to be scared
and we all have our fears i want you to
tackle them in different levels
i don't want you going oh well okay i'm
going to tackle my fears i'm going to go
from
being at home for a month the giant
stadium to see guns and roses you'll
fall apart
just take little baby steps to store
a circle of three a circle of six then
go home be scared for a week or so
test yourself you'll probably be get
[ __ ] up and paranoid
and just linger out guys these four
walls they only get smaller when you're
going through what you're going through
the four walls just get smaller so don't
let
yourself get caught up in four [ __ ]
walls go outside stand on the side of
the [ __ ] building
there's no coconut on the side of your
building there's no cloven on the side
of your house it's just you
want you to breathe look at the sun it's
raining today in jersey do you think
i don't go out cause it rains it rained
monday you should have seen me i was
[ __ ] everywhere
rain don't [ __ ] kill you depression
does
you [ __ ] hide and does you not
expressing yourself that's the [ __ ] that
kills you
you're not letting out your stress
that's what [ __ ] kills you you're not
working it out writing it out
that's what's going to put you in a
[ __ ] hole not the [ __ ] you know
oh i'm gonna die from kobe no you're not
chris christie made it
we're good
once you saw that [ __ ] walk out
of the hospital you were like oh
unless you're in worse shape than he is
you know what i'm saying but if he made
it he's fine
trump's 74 overweight he's [ __ ] fine
listen guys i think the media played
with our heads a little bit
i think that the debts were exaggerated
you guys all know this
and i think that uh right now it's
the virus is [ __ ] you know
mutated and it ain't taken people
take your chances get your life back go
get your life back
or you lost your job start from scratch
go get a new [ __ ] job oh you don't
like your job
well this is the time to get the job you
[ __ ] like
right or wrong it can't get no worse
than this
so go for what you [ __ ] go for it
can't get no worse than this
listen in 1991 i got on stage
i had a job i was making good money i
was flipping cars i was doing rooms on
the side
i wasn't [ __ ] uh you know jeff uh
bose whatever his name is the guy that
owns amazon
the little cuban dude but i was making a
little bit of cash
but was i happy
i was [ __ ] miserable i was [ __ ]
miserable
and then to the grace of god and my
ex-wife some way i got up on stage
the comedy works in denver and
you know it didn't take a [ __ ] genius
when i walked off that stage
i didn't know if this was my calling but
i knew
that it was what i wanted to do i knew i
enjoyed roofing
i enjoyed working with the family i
enjoyed working at day job i'm not a
lazy person
but at the same time i wanted to do
comedy bad
i did it a couple times after i got on
stage the first time
i did a couple times in august i came
back to new york in 91 and snuck some
spots
in some places i was [ __ ] terrible
but i knew it's what i wanted to do
now is in the dilemma how was i going to
do comedy
have a child and you know maintain a
relationship with a wife
when you're 28 that's a tough dilemma to
put together
now i do it because i know exactly what
my duties are
you can't waste time
when you're 28 you don't know that you
still want to go to your buddy's house
and watch the game and play [ __ ]
nintendo whatever [ __ ] football you
[ __ ] plays
madden or whatever once you get a family
all that ends you know all that ends you
got to put all those things aside
i wanted to do comedy so bad but i had
so many [ __ ] things on my plate
i didn't know where the [ __ ] to start
from
when i walked in that [ __ ] house
october 15th which want to come on the
anniversary
on [ __ ] tomorrow when i walked in
that house october 15th
they got lunch something i forgot and my
ex-wife was standing in the kitchen
with a piece of paper we didn't have we
had a kitchen
and then we had like a little desk next
to it it was just like a two-bedroom
condo in boulder
and she was showing me this loan that i
had taken and paid back
and why i had taken it if she was making
such a big deal about i mean there was
no argument nothing
she just said it was time for her to for
us to take a break
and for us to get separated when she
said those words to me
guys it's like the most bittersweet
moment of my life i mean
i didn't want to lose my wife but i did
want to do [ __ ] comedy
i mean i didn't want to lose my wife but
i did want to do comedy
over the weeks she told me yeah you're
still going to have a relationship with
your daughter blah
but i went right for it why because
when we got separated something happened
with the roofing company all of a sudden
they had a big job in jersey
and they couldn't take because they
already had an estimator and a roof
stalker over there
so i was like i was left without a job
so as soon as all this happened what do
you do you want me to cry
i lost like a 70 000 a year job in 1980
[ __ ] 1991 did you want me to cry
yeah i i'm just gonna feel it in my
pocket
but no it was the perfect time to get in
the comedy
because i had nothing to lose so right
now guys you got nothing to lose
if there's something you want to do this
is the time to do it
you're on your [ __ ] grandmother's
couch anyway it can't get no worse than
this
they won't even take your ass at the
shelter so you might as well
go with this for right now and take a
chance
why you could do it
i don't want you to think that having
[ __ ] ten dollars in your pocket is
gonna change your life
no it's not you're still gonna have the
same problems you've always [ __ ] had
we think those skeletons just
miraculously disappear they [ __ ]
don't
so what you need to do is grab your
notebook
start writing and move forward i don't
care whether you want to be a painter
whether you want to do beats you know or
something don't get online every day
wants to do beats
he doesn't know where to start i said
[ __ ] and do beats
i don't know there you go it starts with
a [ __ ] beat
and then figure out the synthesizer i
don't know that world i don't know
nothing about that world
i can't walk them through but don't hit
me what you want to do
it's time to do it you know what i'm
saying i want to do a thousand things i
wish i would have done a thousand things
i wish i would have went to hawaii
i had some more g's and [ __ ] but that
never happened okay i never had noisy in
my life it's disgusting
especially now to think about it let me
see what else i want to cover with you
guys here today we got that
we got that we got
that we got that oh
oh i want to talk to you something about
very important all right
the patreon peers listen i love doing
patreon
i love you [ __ ] to death you
guys were
my therapy august september
you guys were in my therapy i didn't
listen
when you have 14.5 000 people
what's 10 of that that's emails
and you guys know if you're on my
patreon
i answer back emails some are very
simple emails
but some of you guys lay heavy [ __ ] on
me
if i tell you my [ __ ] schedule you
would die with it
day at night i sit down at nine o'clock
on that computer
i kiss my daughter good night and i wrap
up that computer
at one in the morning i mean and that's
just answering emails
no i still gotta do a podcast and i
still gotta [ __ ] do uh
an intro for you guys which i love i
love doing all this stuff
i love being in the car and hearing the
new song and going oh i'm going to use
that for the intro tomorrow
or i wake up it's very that intro is
done very
uh organically you know i wake up in the
morning what song do i want to hear
this morning i gave you what i gave you
bam there you go
there's no drama all i'm trying to do is
get you started
and take your mind somewhere else in the
morning with a little bit of music
you know i used to do it on fate on
twitter where i put the saying
and then i put videos up with the songs
i'm feeling with this i can combine it
it's tremendous you know i'll put on
something and what i'm saying is what
i'm [ __ ] feeling what i got to do
today
like i worked myself up today's a
no-nonsense day
they ain't giving away [ __ ] i start
calling myself a piece of [ __ ] you got
nothing coming
you got to do what you got to do because
it's true everybody's walking around
thinking you got something coming
nowadays you got nothing coming
you know when this [ __ ] pandemic as
though we're gonna throw you out of your
apartment if you didn't pay rent
it's that simple i know people who have
not paid rent since [ __ ] april
and the landlord said this is great but
when your lease is over
you gotta go you know somewhere along
the line you have to face the [ __ ]
realities of this covet situation
so i want you to plan for it listen
people have couches don't be [ __ ] so
proud that you can't ask
don't be so proud that's what i'm saying
i saw that in california
all those high people all those [ __ ]
nitwits
now gotta deal with their jobs and they
don't have jobs and they don't have the
[ __ ] means
to keep living up in studio city trust
me
i had neighbors that were fighting for
their life to put two nickels together
now they're gonna really [ __ ] see it
and you know because it affects your
image
see they live for the joneses out there
i don't live for nobody i live so my
daughter can [ __ ] eat
you follow me i lose some my daughter
could eat i drive a subaru
you don't see me paratrooping and
[ __ ] hawaii i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
here with my family that's almost one
thing i can do
but those people in l.a the people that
were in my neighborhood they have a
certain image to keep
who do you think is paying for those
[ __ ] nannies there's been more
[ __ ] mexican nannies deported on
purpose i guarantee those [ __ ] white
people call the cops
i got an illegal manner here come get it
so i could lose the 1200 a [ __ ] month
because they're running like three
nannies i swear to god
so a bunch of nannies had to get [ __ ]
fired people's had to start drinking you
know
alcohol sales through the [ __ ] roof i
spoke in the drug dealers
cocaine cells up through the [ __ ]
roof you're smoking i'm smoking
we ain't all that broke we're living off
of something some of you [ __ ]
got reefer but the most important thing
is
you living for the jones [ __ ]
it's gonna be a little tough now
when the jones are related to covet huh
huh how does it feel now
talking about your boats and [ __ ] forget
that [ __ ]
forget that [ __ ] now that those la
people gonna [ __ ] feel it with all
that [ __ ]
and listen my heart goes out to them
they drank the tea
in two thousand [ __ ] five when i
drank the longest yard
i drank the tea but in 2006 when i
realized i was still the same piece of
[ __ ] i was
it was all over the t [ __ ] wore off
and i realized what that game was about
and it's about [ __ ] just doing what
you do and pushing [ __ ] forward
and you can't worry about what this guy
is doing or that guy
oh he's got a new car i gotta buy a new
car you don't gotta buy dick
[ __ ] him what else you don't know is
that motherfucker's paying 800 a month
and you can't borrow 800. you come to me
and say listen i
i i can't make my my fourth payment it's
240. i'll give it to you
240 ain't [ __ ] but you come to me for an
800 car payment
i might lend you half the first time
the second time i'll suggest that you
light the car on fire
or we can let on fire together i know
exactly how to [ __ ] do it i've been
found cars on fire before it's no big
deal
but right now is a good time to look at
your finances to see what you you know
what you can live off and what you live
off of cable is [ __ ] high
i look at cable every night and i go why
the [ __ ] do i pay all this money
i only watch one [ __ ] channel and
that's just once a week
i watch cbs 60 minutes once a week if i
watch football it's in florentine's
house
or something like that i watch that much
[ __ ] tv last time i went upstairs my
wife was watching some lady with some
tattoo
on the leg get the [ __ ] out of here i
came right down and went back to
answering [ __ ] emails i don't watch
[ __ ] tv
so if you're not watching that much tv
cut cut cut
you don't got to deal with the joneses
no more it's [ __ ] covered gun sucker
and that's it i don't even know what
else to [ __ ] tell you i'm nice and
[ __ ] high
rule number one don't get high into one
it's been happening to me the last
couple times
the last two podcasts i did i paid for
those [ __ ] after the cameras
got turned off
the first one was that spray day where i
did about 19 sprays
i didn't feel it like three o'clock and
[ __ ] monday
sunday's podcast i ate a 200 milligram
capsule
i'm not doing that no more [ __ ] at 10
o'clock in the morning
that was a big mistake i found myself
nodding during the [ __ ] miami dolphin
game
like a heroin junk you had to get up and
[ __ ] eat 22 chicken wings
thank god i didn't gain no weight and
weight watts is all right with chicken
that doesn't have the sauce on it but we
all got [ __ ] problems but
i will tell you one thing if you have a
chance this weekend or if you don't have
a chance or if you
just find somebody with showtime i think
you [ __ ] pirate the app
i don't i don't [ __ ] know i don't
know nothing about that
i just had you know a lot of people
emailed me and said they saw me on it
if you get a chance watch the last three
episodes if you get a chance
watch all the five episodes it is very
interesting
you know i sit here and i say [ __ ]
sometimes that
it's not alive but it's not correct in
the way i say it
i was part of something i wasn't part of
a crime organization or the mafia i was
part of the [ __ ] comedy mafia
i was part of something that was so
[ __ ] big
and now that i'm here and i see it
i was so proud of i was so [ __ ] proud
of
i didn't do a lot of good things in my
life
but life god buddha
whoever the [ __ ] led me to the [ __ ]
comedy store
just led me to the comedy store you know
i got off that [ __ ]
i drove down with my girlfriend the
stripper in the trailer
we were pulling the [ __ ] mazda
excuse me and we landed i gotta be
honest with you we landed in la
at 7
15 at night
we're going down the 101 exited we
didn't know we were going we had a
trailer
a [ __ ] yeah one of those [ __ ] rvs
we were [ __ ] towing a [ __ ] car
and we had a dog in the rv i didn't know
where the [ __ ] to go
we pulled up on fairfax boulevard we
disconnected the car
we went to acapulco aka the sycamore
tavern with sam triply ram
that's that's what that what place was
acapulco mexican restaurant
it was all you could eat i [ __ ] went
down there with my girlfriend i ate
dinner
and there was only one place to go on
that monday night
you know january 29th there was only one
place to go
and i went right to the comedy store
when i and they didn't let me park on
the lot
i had to pay to park and walk in like a
civilian
but i walked around the back and it was
just amazing
i saw a couple comics i had known james
stevens the third it was monday night
i think it was an open mic night i meant
wheels i saw the guy from the last
dragon
with eddie griffin i saw eddie griffin
didn't say anything to anybody
i just sat there and i watched the show
i talked to bill barris i forget that
that's his name embarrassed i
i forget now because i'm high and uh
don barris i'm sorry don barris i spoke
with don barris it was funny
i was just watching a video about van
halen on uh
jimmy kimmel and i don't know something
that happened
and they were they were running late and
it's a
it's a [ __ ] video of don barris with
his suit on
pushing the [ __ ] crowd back as a
jimmy kimmel warm up
[ __ ] tremendous if you can see it i
saw a couple great videos this weekend
you get a chance if you want to watch a
real podcasting
the beginnings of podcasting there's a
[ __ ]
howard stern with audi lang and robin
and dice calls in because arty lang
did a gig for dice and dice never paid
him the five grand it was two weeks
later
and already got mad you listen man to do
a good podcast
you gotta watch the old howard stern
shows
because that was the beginning of the
podcast and they didn't know it
because it was a different level of
opening up
artie was really doing some you know i
haven't heard from marty
uh i reached out to him a couple of
times
i hear he's doing well i hear he's
scared of cobin he's taking his
he's taking care of his mother but most
importantly is that he's clean
but i don't give a [ __ ] what you
[ __ ] think of hardy
he's made some mistakes and he's done
some heroin
so what who gives a [ __ ] when artie lang
was on stern those are some of the best
[ __ ] years
of radio as far as i'm concerned
you won't argue with me argue with me
and they were the beginnings of
podcasting
because it wasn't like hey you just
heard eric clapton slowing it no
it was just these guys talking and he
went from this chubby
little italian guy that was doing blow
and gambling
and he right before your eyes he changed
this to this guy that was now wearing
sunglasses
and was talking about going ahead and
getting heroin and [ __ ] like that
it's brilliant if you're starting a
podcast
if you're thinking of starting one if
you're doing a podcast
if you think you could be doing a little
better let me tell you what i
because listen three quarters of the
[ __ ] i do here
is stern and rogue and combined that's
it
and i add my own personal flavor and i
talk from the heart of my balls
well let's be honest with you you know
we all have influences for something
uh for comedy it's always been lenny
bruce and richard pryor for me you know
for music it's always been you know eric
clapton david gilmour's guitar
you know uh [ __ ] uh
bottoms drumming you know robert plant
what he does on stage with his body
you know it's always been something uh
when it comes to podcasting
my two [ __ ] uh heroes were howard
stern
and joe rogan i mean they just somewhere
i wanted to be in the middle of that
i don't have the intelligence of rogan i
don't have the interviewing skills with
how it's turned
but i got the heart and i've studied
them both
and i try to bring that to you guys so
always remember that before you
go into something you gotta have a guide
some guy that you're watching that
you're going hmm
is that he's doing it i thought i'm a
fan of that [ __ ]
i like what he's doing but i would do it
differently
that's where the art comes in that's
where the word art comes in
and creativity you know uh
this is what this has been you know this
is not a brain surgery here guys
this is not brain surgery this is a wall
a couple iphones
a [ __ ] portable mic that's on the
[ __ ] thing that picks up everything
i mean last time i went to tape [ __ ]
thing for you guys
and i had to go upstairs and tell my
wife to turn the tv down
but that that [ __ ] microphone you
can't have a conversation if you have a
conversation on the block
the fbi can take into that microphone
and clean it up and hear the [ __ ]
conversation down the block
these mics are great this ain't no for
cost 49.95
69 on [ __ ] amazon you're looking to
start a podcast just go to [ __ ]
amazon
i promised you guys i didn't want to
come up with glitter and glam
i will promise you one thing though
i think for the khabib fight i'll have
the bar ready for you [ __ ]
and i'll do like one of those fight type
things we'll we'll watch the fight
with the last five fights in the card
i'll talk about it i'll get somebody to
come up you know
it won't be a big time production or
nothing but that by that time i could
probably give you the first glimpse of
the bar
that's what i'm going to use it for for
sporting events
maybe we'll do a movie podcast sometime
and we'll do it in there
look the wheels are [ __ ] spinning
[ __ ] sucker
i'm not just sitting here [ __ ] uh you
know jerking off here i'm [ __ ]
thinking i'm thinking of better ways
to because i think they're gonna lock
things down somewhere
i hope not you know my daughter's going
to school
i hope a kid don't [ __ ] sneeze first
kid that's
neat you know i lose my my daughter's
things she got [ __ ] allergies
that's why she drives me crazy when she
sneezes too but
you know if they close this down which i
hope not i hope
that i'm not crazy you know i don't know
how cold
december and january is but i just want
to keep doing with this with you this is
it
it's not going to be no [ __ ] big
lights and hollywood produ
i don't need the aggravation all we're
doing here is [ __ ] communicating
and if this is the easiest way to do it
so be it you got everybody here you got
bruce lee
you got sid the squid moncrief you got
palisade amusement park
you got my man charles bronson and you
got ac dc
five days four days before i saw him the
first time
that's june 30th i saw him august 4th
what's the [ __ ] difference
who gives a [ __ ] it don't make me no
better than you [ __ ]
all i'm saying is we're here and we're
queer
the joint is [ __ ] done episode four
what did we learn today if you got
offended by bill byrne
just [ __ ] jump off a bridge leave me
the [ __ ] alone okay
leave me the [ __ ] alone number two bert
christ is a bad [ __ ]
give him the respect he deserves he
comes to your town
i don't care if you go after the show
and just buy a ten dollar hat
support number three watched the comedy
store documentary
it means the world to me it means the
world to me
download the showtime mat showtime's got
some great other shows on there
also and watch that documentary because
uh it means the world to me that
somebody took the time
it means the world to me that after i
punch the ticket
people are gonna watch that [ __ ]
thing and go wow
we didn't know he was a part of that yes
i was with all my felonies
and all my problems and all my
addictions i was still a [ __ ] part of
that
you know i came there i don't know 15
years
or maybe i don't know 10 years after
kennison's [ __ ] crew rolled out of
there
we came up there with a whole new crew
in 98
and we took it straight to 2007. i took
a couple years off i came back to the
store in 2013
and dawg i closed that [ __ ] on
march 3rd
so guess what i'm like a [ __ ] captain
up there
in that [ __ ] comedy store i paid my
dues a lot of people became regulars and
didn't [ __ ] make it out
i walked off that stage march 3rd the
same way i walked out of that podcast
studio
with my head held high i gave you the
best job i could give you
and i walked out of there with [ __ ]
dignity into the [ __ ] sunlight
you can't [ __ ] beat that guys and
that's all i'm trying to tell you
don't ever let nobody tell you it's time
to go like i'm doing right now
i'm going to bow out of this one because
i'm a little too high
i love you [ __ ] with all my
heart thank you for supporting the
sponsors
this week's is blue chew you got to work
on your dick
and stamps.com you got to up your
business game
you want to sell globes get to selling
[ __ ] globes
getstamps.com that's it and that's that
i love you [ __ ] with all my
heart patreon three
five ten fifteen dollars
you get the album review you get the
[ __ ] lens
you get [ __ ] you got everything and
everybody gets a little work money
everybody gets a little [ __ ] dip
you know it's just this doesn't just go
in my pocket i'm not being
i spread it around a little bit people
need money people need help
my man one by one podcast is helping me
thank god he's one of the most creative
guys i've met in [ __ ] he is
great man my man lee is up in milwaukee
he put out a new podcast please support
him because we're going to be going back
and forth
and once he gets to boston i'll be doing
zoom appearances on him
even though i don't like zoom for lee
i'll do whatever the [ __ ] he needs
because i want him to tell his least
podcast i hope
he does it like aerosmith did that book
two guys telling their view
on that particular night and i'm like
ralphie knights or whatever i could call
in
but do me that favor and support lisa
anybody else for your support
during this time you know i give you my
[ __ ] soul with this
you know i answer my messages on patreon
we cut the messages from three dollars
to five
and it's now called dear abby and i did
that for a reason because i want you to
contact me with real problems
not what kind of weed you smoking joey i
already post those pictures up
so we switched that up on the 15 t you
get everything
and you get merch but you do not get it
till january first
this is what i'm saying to you why
because we're backed up
we got the design what do you want me to
do put it on my [ __ ] forehead
i can't do that
it only comes in xl and large but
let me talk to them i got a lot of
[ __ ]
xl3s and xo4s that i sell that i know
are gonna want stuff so i'm gonna try to
[ __ ]
do that for you also okay the three
dollar one you guys are the dollar ones
that came on
you're getting everything except the
album thing
the live videos and the messaging why
because you guys are the ones
that were messaging me a lot and the
people that were giving more money
weren't messaging me at all so i had to
cut that down a little bit
if you want to talk to me and keep up
the conversation
you're gonna get everything else in the
fence so what do you give a [ __ ]
i'm gonna talk to them today about hats
and try to get those out
sooner than later and that's it and
that's that guys
i'm trying my hardest to bring you
comfort
to bring you happiness and a [ __ ]
little laughter for a couple minutes
every week all right
go to patreon.com joey diaz
the podcast this is always free i don't
give a [ __ ]
nothing interferes in this this is my
communication with the world
i i put it up on patreon also so i don't
have to [ __ ] around with it or whatnot
but that's it and that's that listen
it's the 14th of [ __ ] october
we're halfway there we're two months
away from the new year
i don't know what the [ __ ] to tell you
have a great [ __ ] weekend
i'll be lurking this weekend i'm gonna
hit you with a little surprise video
or surprise something you're gonna now
another week
maybe i don't know i'm only giving you
two a month
but i might drop three on you because
i'm a nice guy you know what i'm saying
stay black have a great day have a great
weekend uncle joey loves you
all right [ __ ] like i told you in
the beginning uncle joey's joint is
brought to you by
blue chew remember when your dick would
be hard just because the wind would blow
just like that your [ __ ] dick would
be hard
you would rub it through your jeans you
didn't know what to do
yeah you get all the stress
see you know covet the whole thing all
of a sudden you start getting
the weak become the wood becomes a
little weak
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] i gotta fix that
problem right now it's bad enough you
can't go to work
it's bad enough you [ __ ] can't go
anywhere at least you get got to give
mom a little stab
and that's where blue chew comes in blue
chews are prescribed online
by licensed physicians so you don't have
to go to the doctor's office
and wait online at the pharmacy you know
how embarrassing it is to ask you back
to the [ __ ]
viagra or seattle or whatever the [ __ ]
it is
blue chew is cheaper than the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door
in a discreet little package nobody
knows
nothing you understand me remember the
days remember that [ __ ]
well they're back [ __ ] with blue
chew like i said
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and you
could take them any time
day and night even on a full stomach
right now they got a special offer for
the joint listeners you ready visit
bootshoe.com
that's blue chew b-l-u-e chew
dot-com and get your first shipment free
when you're pressing code church
just pay the five dollar shipping again
and that's blue
that's it just file a shipping and again
that's blue like the color
of your [ __ ] helmet you understand
you ever get that helmet to turn blue no
now is the time you're not dead yet you
don't want to die on facetime with
[ __ ] dead dick anyway
it's going to be popping when you hit
that blue chew dog
dot com use code joey j-o-e-y
bluechew.com use code joey and thank
them for continuing to sponsor
the joints i also want to thank
stamps.com [ __ ] tremendous this is a
service that listen
if you're in business small or large you
can't live without
plain and simple stamps.com brings the
post office
into the comfort of your own [ __ ]
home skip the line print postage 24 7
yourself
at home any letter any size package
going anywhere
in this [ __ ] great world right now
from your account you can send anything
anything
you can send a [ __ ] light to somebody
in bulgaria
who gives a [ __ ] and the best part is
the mailman will come
and pick it up no contact required it's
that [ __ ] simple for you [ __ ]
coping people
who are scared to leave your [ __ ]
bathroom you also get great discounts
you get five cents off every first class
stamp
and up to forty percent are priority
mail plus you save up to 62
on ups rates where the [ __ ] you gonna
get those numbers from
uncle joey so don't spend the minute of
your holiday season
at the post office this year stamps.com
is a no-brainer especially now
saving you time money and keeping you
safe there's no risk
with my code church c-h-u-r-c-h you got
a special offer that includes
a four-week trial plus ready for this
free postage and a digital scale
i told you i got the digital scale but i
can't put it up here i got problems
no long-term commitments or contracts
it's easy go to stamps.com
click the microphone on the top of the
homepage and press in church that
stamps.com
press in church and never go to that
[ __ ] post office again
i want to thank stamps i want dot com i
want to thank bluetooth.com
but most importantly i want to thank you
guys for being here uncle joey's joint
loves you constructors
stay black
there you go i don't want to be like
that guy in the ceo
copd commercial you can't grandpa you
can't block the candles go [ __ ] yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you